The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right,
guys, let's get started.
So today, we're going to talk
about side-channel attacks,
which is a general class
of problems that comes up
in all kinds of systems.
Broadly, side-channel
attacks are
situations where you haven't
thought about some information
that your system
might be revealing.
So typically, you have multiple
components that you [INAUDIBLE]
maybe a user talking
to some server.
And you're thinking, great,
I know exactly all the bits
going over some wire [INAUDIBLE]
server, and those are secure.
But it's often easy to miss
some information revealed,
either by user or by server.
So the example that the
paper for today talks about
is a situation where the
timing of the messages
between the user and
the server reveals
some additional information
that you wouldn't have otherwise
learned by just observing the
bits flowing between these two
guys.
But In fact, there's a much
broader class of side-channels
you might worry about.
Originally,
side-channels showed up,
or people discovered them in
the '40s when they discovered
that when you start
typing characters
on a teletype the electronics,
or the electrical machinery
in the teletype, would
emit RF radiation.
And you can hook up
an oscilloscope nearby
and just watch the
characters being typed out
by monitoring the frequency
or RF frequencies that
are going out of this machine.
So RF radiation is a classic
example of a side-channel
that you might worry about.
And there's lots of examples
lots of other examples
that people have looked
at, almost anything.
So power usage is
another side-channel
you might worry about.
So your computer
is probably going
to use different amounts of
power depending on what exactly
it's computing.
I'm gonna go into other
clever examples of sound
turns out to also leak stuff.
There's a [? cute ?] paper
that you can look at.
The people listen to a
printer and based on the sound
the printer is
making you can tell
what characters it's printing.
This is especially easy to do
for dot matrix printers that
make this very annoying
sound when they're printing.
And in general, a good
thing to think about,
Kevin on Monday's
lecture also mentioned
some interesting side-channels
that he's running through
in his research.
But, in particular,
here we're going
to look at the
specific side-channel
that David Brumley and Dan Boneh
looked at in their paper-- I
guess about 10 years ago now--
where they were able to extract
a cryptographic key out of
a web server running Apache
by measuring the timing
of different responses
to different input packets
from the adversarial client.
And in this particular
case, they're
going after a cryptographic key.
In fact, many
side-channel attacks
target cryptographic keys
partly because it's a little bit
tricky to get lots of data
through a side-channel.
And cryptographic
keys are one situation
where getting a small number
of bits helps you a lot.
So in their attack they're
able to extract maybe
about 200 256 bits or so.
And just from those
200ish bits, they're
able to break the cryptographic
key of this web server.
Whereas, if you're
trying to leak
some database full of
Social Security numbers,
then that'll be
a lot of bits you
have to leak to get
out of this database.
So that's why many of
these side-channels,
if you'll see them
later on, they often
focus on getting
small secrets out,
might be cryptographic
keys or passwords.
But in general, this
is applicable to lots
of other situations as well.
And one cool thing
about this paper,
before we jump into
the details, is
that they show that you actually
do this over the network.
So as you probably figured
out from reading this paper,
they have to do a
lot of careful work
to tease out these
minute differences
in timing information.
So if you actually compute out
the numbers from this paper,
it turns out that each request
that they sent to the server
differs from potentially
another [? website ?]
by an order of 1 to
2 microseconds, which
is pretty tiny.
So you have to be quite
careful, and all of our network
it might be hard to tell
whether some server took
1 or 2 microseconds longer to
process your request or not.
And as a result, it was not
so clear for whether you
could mount this kind of attack
over a very noisy network.
And these guys were
one of the first people
to show that you can actually
do this over a real ethernet
network with a server sitting
in one place, a client sitting
somewhere else.
And you could actually
measure these differences
partly by averaging, partly
through other tricks.
All right, does that make sense,
the overall side-channel stuff?
All right.
So the plan for the
rest of this lecture
is we'll first dive into
the details of this RSA
cryptosystem that
these guys use.
Then we'll not look at
exactly why it's secure
or not but we'll look at
how do you implement it
because that turns out to
be critical for exploiting
this particular side-channel.
They carefully leverage various
details of the implementation
to figure out when there are
some things faster or slower.
And then we'll pop back
out once we understand
how RSA is implemented.
Then we'll come back and figure
out how do you attack it,
how do you attack all these
different organizations
that RSA has.
Sounds good?
All right.
So I guess let's
start off by looking
at the high level plan for RSA.
So RSA is a pretty widely
used public key cryptosystem.
We've mentioned these
guys a couple of weeks
ago in general in certificates,
in the context of certificates.
But now we're going to look
at actually how it works.
So typically there's 3 things
you have to worry about.
So there's generating a key,
encrypting, and decrypting.
So for RSA, the way you
generate a key is you actually
pick 2 large prime integers.
So you're going to
pick 2 primes, p and q.
And in the paper, these
guys focus on p and q,
which are about 512 bits each.
So this is typically
called 1,024 bit RSA
because the resulting product
of these primes that you're
going to use in a second is
a 1,000 bit integer number.
These days, that's probably
not a particularly good choice
for the size of your
RSA key because it
makes it relatively easy for
attackers to factor this-- not
trivial but certainly viable.
So if 10 years ago, this seemed
like a potentially sensible
parameter, now if you're
actually building a system,
you should probably
pick a 2,000 or 3,000
or even 4,000 bit RSA key.
Well, that's what
RSA key size means
is the size of these primes.
And then, for
convenience, we're going
to talk about the
number n, which
is just the product of
these 2 primes, p times q.
All right.
So now we know how
to generate a key,
now we need to figure
out-- well this is at least
part of a key-- now
we're going to have
to figure out how we're going
to encrypt and decrypt messages.
And the way we're going to
encrypt and decrypt messages
is by exponentiating numbers
modulo this number n.
So it seems a little weird, but
let's go with it for a second.
So if you want to
encrypt a message,
then we're going
to take a message m
and transform it into
m to the power e mod m.
So e is going to be some
exponent-- we'll talk about how
to choose it in a second.
But this is how we're
going to encrypt a message.
We'll just take this
message as an integer number
and just exponentiate it.
And then we'll see why
this works in a second,
but let's call this
guy c, ciphertext.
Then to decrypt it, we're
going to somehow find
an interesting
other exponent where
you can take a ciphertext c
and if you exponentiate it
to some power d mod m,
then you'll magically
get back the same message m.
So this is the general plan:
To encrypt, you exponentiate.
To decrypt, you exponentiate
by another exponent.
And in general, it
seems a little hard
to figure out how we're going
to come up with these two
magic numbers that
somehow end up giving us
back the same message.
But it turns out
that if you look
at how exponentiation works
or multiplication works,
modulo of this number n.
Then there's this cool property
that if you have any number x,
and you raise it to what's
called a [? order ?] of phi
function of n-- maybe I'll
use more board space for this.
This seems important.
So if you take x and you
raise it to phi of n,
then this is going to
be equal to 1 mod m.
And this phi function for
our particular choice of n
is pretty straightforward,
it's actually
p minus 1 times q minus 1.
So this gives us hope that maybe
if we pick ed so that e times
d is 5n plus 1, then
we're in good shape.
Because then any message m we
exponentiate it to e and d,
we get back 1 times m
because our ed product
is going to be
roughly 5n plus 1,
or maybe some constant
alpha times 5n plus 1.
Does this make sense?
This is why the message is going
to get decrypted correctly.
And it turns out that there's
a reasonably straightforward
algorithm if you know this
phi value for how to compute
d given an e or e given a d.
All right.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Isn't 1 mod n just 1?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
far we add one more.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Like, up over there.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, this one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Isn't 1 mod n just 1?
Sorry, I mean this.
So when I say this 1 n, it
means that both sides taken 1n
are equal.
So what this means
is if you want
to think of mod as
literally an operator,
you would write this guy
mod m equals 1 mod m.
So that's what mod
m on the side means.
Like, the whole
equality is mod m.
Sorry for the [INAUDIBLE].
Make sense?
All right.
So what this basically
means for RSA is that we're
going to pick some value e.
So e is going to be
our encryption value.
And then from e we're going
to generate d to be basically
1 over e mod phi of n.
And there's some
Euclidean algorithms
you can use to do this
computation efficiently.
But in order to do
this you actually
have to know this
phi of n, which
requires knowing the
factorization of our number n
into p and q.
All right.
So finally, RSA ends
up being a system where
the public key is this number n
and this encryption exponent e.
So n and e are public,
and d should be private.
So then anyone can
exponentiate a message
to encrypt it for you.
But only you know this
value d and therefore
can decrypt messages.
And as long as you don't know
this factorization of p and q,
of n to p and q,
then you don't know
what this [? phi del ?] is.
And as a result, it's
actually difficult to compute
this d value.
So this is roughly what RSA is.
High level.
Does this make sense?
All right.
So there's 2 things I
want to talk about now
that we at least have the basic
[? implementation ?] for RSA.
There's tricks to use it
correctly and pitfalls
and how to use RSA.
And then there's all kinds
of implementation tricks
on how do you actually
implement [? root ?]
code to do these exponentiations
and do them efficiently.
There's actually more
trivial because these are all
large numbers, these are 1,000
bit integers that can't just
do a multiply instruction for.
Probably going to take
a fair amount of time
to do these operations.
All right.
So the first thing
I want to mention
is the various RSA pitfalls.
One of them we're actually going
to rely on in a little bit.
One property is, that
it's multiplicative.
So what I mean by this is that
suppose we have 2 messages.
Suppose we have m0 and m1.
And suppose I
encrypt these guys,
so I encrypt m0, I'm going to
get m0 to the power e mod n.
And if I encrypt m1, then
I'd get m1 to the e mod n.
The problem is-- not
necessarily a problem
but could be a
surprise to someone
using RSA-- it's
very easy to generate
an encryption of m0
times m1 because you just
multiply these 2 numbers.
If you multiply these
guys out, you're
going to get m0
m1 to the e mod n.
This is a correct encryption
under this simplistic use
of RSA for the
value m0 times m1.
I mean at this point,
it's not a huge problem
because if you aren't
able to decrypt it,
you're just able to construct
this encrypted message.
But it might be that the
overall system maybe allows you
to decrypt certain messages.
And if it allows you to decrypt
this message that you construct
yourself, maybe you can
now go back and figure out
what are these messages.
So it's maybe not a great plan
to be ignorant of this fact.
This has certainly come back
to bite a number of protocols
that use RSA.
There's one property,
we'll actually
use it as a defensive mechanism
towards the end of the lecture.
Another property of RSA that you
probably want to watch out for
is the fact that
it's deterministic.
So in this [? naive ?]
implementation
that I just described here,
if you take a message m
and you encrypt it,
you're going to get m
to the e mod n, which is
a deterministic function
of the message.
So if you encrypt
it again, you'll
get exactly the same encryption.
This is not surprising
but it might not
be a desirable
property because if I
see you send send some
message encrypted with RSA,
and I want to know what
it is, it might be hard
for me to decrypt it.
But I can try different
things and I can see,
well are you sending
this message?
I'll encrypt it and see if
you get the same ciphertext.
And if so, then I'll know
that's what you encrypted.
Because all I need to
encrypt a message is
the publicly known public key,
which is n and the number e.
So that's not so great.
And you might want to
watch out for this property
if you're actually using RSA.
So all of these
[? primitives are ?]
probably a little bit
hard to use directly.
What people do in
practice in order
to avoid these
problems with RSA is
they encode the message
in a certain way
before encrypting it.
Instead of directly
exponentiating a message,
it actually takes some
function of a message,
and then they encrypt that.
mod n.
And this function f, the
right one to use these days,
is probably something called
optimal asymmetric encryption
padding, O A E P.
You can look it up.
It's something coded that has
two interesting properties.
First of all, it
injects randomness.
You can think of f of n as
generating 1,000 bit message
that you're going to encrypt.
Part of this message is going to
be your message m in the middle
here.
So that you can get it back
when you decrypt, of course.
[INAUDIBLE].
So there's 2 interesting
things you want to do.
You want to put in
some randomness here,
some value r so that when
you encrypt the message
multiple times, you'll
get different results out
of each time so then it's
not deterministic anymore.
And in order to defeat this
multiplicative property
and other kinds of
problems, you're
going to put in some
fixed padding here.
You can think of this as
an altering sequence of 1 0
1 0 1 0.
You can do better things.
But roughly it's some
predictable sequence
that you put in here and
whenever you decrypt,
you make sure the
sequence is still there.
Even in multiplication
it's going
to destroy this bit power.
And then you should be
clear that someone tampered
with my message and reject it.
And if it's still there, then
presumably, sometimes provably,
no one tampered with your
message, and as a result
you should be able to accept it.
And treat message m as
correctly encrypted by someone.
Make sense?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If the attacker knows
how big the pad is, can't they
put a 1 in the lowest
place and then [INAUDIBLE]
under multiplication?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, maybe.
It's a little bit tricky
because this randomness
is going to bleed over.
So the particular
construction of this O A E P
is a little bit more
sophisticated than this.
But if you imagine
this is integer
multiplication not
bit-wise multiplication.
And so this randomness is
going to bleed over somewhere,
and you can construct
O A E P scheme such
that this doesn't happen.
[INAUDIBLE] Make sense?
All right.
So it turns out that
basically you shouldn't really
use this RSA math
directly, you should
use some library in
practice that implements all
those things correctly for you.
And use it just as an
encrypt/decrypt parameter.
But it turns out these details
will come in and matter
for us because we're
actually trying to figure out
how to break or how to attack
an existing RSA implementation.
So in particular the
attack from this paper
is going to exploit the
fact that the server is
going to check for this padding
when they get a message.
So this is how we're going to
time how long it takes a server
to decrypt.
We're going to send some random
message, or some carefully
constructed message.
But the message wasn't
constructed by taking a real m
and encrypting it.
We're going to construct a
careful ciphertext integer
value.
And the server is
going to decrypt it,
it's going to decrypt
to some nonsense,
and the padding is
going to not match
with a very high probability.
And immediately the server
is going to reject it.
And the reason this
is going to be good
for us is because it will tell
us exactly how long it took
the server to get to this point,
just do the RSA decryption,
get this message, check
the padding, and reject it.
So that's what we're
going to be measuring
in this attack from the paper.
Does that make sense?
So there's some integrity
component to the the message
that allows us to time the
decryption leading up to it.
All right.
So now let's talk about how to
do you actually implement RSA.
So the core of it is
really this exponentiation,
which is not exactly
trivial to do
as I was mentioning earlier
because all these numbers are
very large integers.
So the message itself
is going to be at least,
in this paper,
1,000 bit integer.
And the exponent itself is
also going to be pretty large.
The encryption exponent
is at least well known.
But the decryption
exponent better
be also a large integer also
on the order of 1,000 bits.
So you have a 1,000
bit integer you
want to exponentiate to another
1,000 bit integer power modulo
some other 1,000
bit integer n that's
going to be a little
messy, if you just do
[? the naive thing. ?]
So almost everyone has
lots of optimizations in
their RSA implementations
to make this go a
little bit faster.
And there's four
optimizations that matter
for the purpose of this attack.
There is actually more
tricks that you can play,
but the most important
ones are these.
So first there's something
called the Chinese remainder
theorem, or C R T.
And just to remind you
from grade school or
high school maybe what
this remainder theorem says.
It actually says that
if you have two numbers
and you have some
value x and you know
that x is equal to a1 mod p.
And you know that x is
equal to a2 mod q, where
p and q are prime numbers.
And this modular equality
applies to the whole equation.
Then it turns out that there's
a unique solution to this
is mod p q.
So there's are some x equals
to some x prime mod pq.
And in fact, there's
a unique such x prime,
and it's actually very
efficient to compute.
So the Chinese
remainder theorem also
comes with an algorithm for
how to compute this unique x
prime that's equal to x mod pq
given the values a1 and a2 mod
p and q, respectively.
Make sense?
OK, so how can you use this
Chinese remainder theorem
to speed up modular
exponentiation?
So the way this is
going to help us
is that if you
notice all the time
we're doing this computational
of some bunch of stuff modulo
n, which is p times q.
And the Chinese
remainder theorem
says that if you want the value
of something mod p times q,
it suffices to compute the
value of that thing mod p
and the value of
that thing mod q.
And then use the Chinese
remainder theorem
to figure out the
unique solution to what
this thing is mod p times q.
All right, why is this faster?
Seems like you're basically
doing the same thing twice,
and that's more
work to recombine it
Is this going to
save me anything?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, they're
certainly smaller,
they're not that smaller.
And so p and q, so n
is 1,000 bits, p and q
are both 500 bits, they're not
quite to the machine word size
yet.
But it is going to
help us because most
of the stuff we're doing
in this computation
is all these multiplications.
And roughly multiplication
is quadratic in the size
of the thing you're multiplying
because the grade school
method of multiplication
you take all the digits
and multiply them by all the
other digits in the number.
And as a result, doing
exponentiation multiplication
is roughly quadratic
in the input side.
So if we shrink the value of p,
we basically go from 1,000 bits
to 512 bits, we reduce the
size of our input by 2.
So this means all this
multiplication exponentiation
is going to be roughly
4 times cheaper.
So even though we do it twice,
each time is 4 times faster.
So overall, the
CRT optimization is
going to give us
basically a 2x performance
boost for doing any
RSA operation both,
in the encryption
and decryption side.
That make sense?
All right.
So that's the first optimization
that most people use.
The second thing that
most implementations do
is a technique called
sliding windows.
And we'll look at this
implementation in 2 steps
so this implementation is
going to be concerned with what
basic operations
are going to perform
to do this exponentiation.
Suppose you have some
ciphertext c that's now 500 bits
because you were not
doing mod p or mod q.
We have a 500 bit c and,
similarly, roughly a 500 bit d
as well.
So how do we raise
c to the power d?
I guess the stupid way
that is to take c and keep
multiplying d times.
But d is very big,
it's 2 to the 500.
So that's never going to finish.
So a more amenable,
or more performant,
plan is to do what's
called repeat of squaring.
So that's the step
before sliding windows.
So this technique called
repeated squaring looks
like this.
So if you want to compute
c to the power 2 x,
then you can actually compute
c to the x and then square it.
So in our naive plan,
computing c to the 2x
would have involved us making
twice as many iterations
of multiplying because it's
multiplying c twice many times.
But in fact, you could be
clever and just compute
c to the x and then
square it later.
So this works well,
and this means
that if you're computing c to
some even exponent, this works.
And conversely, if you're
computing c to some 2x plus 1,
then you could
imagine this is just
c to the x squared
times another c.
So this is what's called
repeated squaring.
And this now allows us to
compute these exponentiations,
or modular exponentiations,
in a time that's
basically linear in the
size of the exponent.
So for every bit
in the exponent,
we're going to either
square something
or square something then
do an extra multiplication.
So that's the plan
for repeated squaring.
So now we can at least have
non-embarrassing run times
for computing modular exponents.
Does this make sense, why this
is working and why it's faster?
All right, so what's this
sliding windows trick
that the paper talks about?
So this is a little bit
more sophisticated than this
repeating squaring business.
And basically the
squaring is going
to be pretty much inevitable.
But what the sliding windows
optimization is trying do
is reduce the overhead of
multiplying by this extra c
down here.
So suppose if you
have some number that
has several 1 bits in the
exponent, for every 1 bit
in the exponent in the
binder of presentation,
you're going to have do this
step instead of this step.
Because for every
odd number, you're
going to have to multiply by c.
So these guys would like to not
multiply by this c as often.
So the plan is to precompute
different powers of c.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to generate
a table that says,
well, here's the value of c
to the x-- sorry, c to the 1--
here's the value of c
to the 3, c to the 7.
And I think
[? in open ?] as a cell,
it goes up to c to the 31st.
So this table is
going to just be
precomputed when you want to
do some modular exponentiation.
You're going to precompute
all the slots in this table.
And then when you want to do
this exponentiation, instead
of doing the repeated squaring
and multiplying by this c
every time,
You're going to use
a different formula.
It says as well if you have
c to the 32x plus some y,
well you can do c
to the x, and you
can do repeated squaring--
very much like before-- this
is to get the 32, there's
like 5 powers of 2 here
times c to the y.
And c to the y, you can
get out of this table.
So you can see that we're doing
the same number of squaring
as before here.
But we don't have to
multiply by c as many times.
You're going to fish
it out of this table
and do several multiplies
by c for the cost
of a single multiply.
This make sense?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How do you determine
x and y in the first place?
PROFESSOR: How do determine y?
AUDIENCE: X and y.
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK.
So let's look at that.
So for repeated
squaring, well actually
in both cases,
what you want to do
is you want to look
at the exponent
that you're trying to use
in a binary representation.
So suppose I'm trying to compute
the value of c to the exponent,
I don't know, 1 0 1 1 0 1 0,
and maybe there's more bits.
OK, so if we wanted to
do repeated squaring,
then you look at the
lowest bit here-- it's 0.
So what you're
going to write down
is this is equal to c to
the 1 0 1 1 0 1 squared.
OK, so now if only
you knew this value,
then you could just square it.
OK, now we're going to compute
this guy, so c to the 1 0 1 1
0 1 is equal to-- well
here we can't use this rule
because it's not 2x-- it's
going to be to the x plus 1.
So now we're going to write
this is c to the 1 0 1 1 0
squared times another c.
Because it's this prefix
times 2 plus this one of m.
That's how you fish it
out for repeated squaring.
And for sliding window,
you just grab more bits
from the low end.
So if you wanted to do the
sliding window trick here
instead of taking
one c out, suppose
we do-- instead of this
giant table-- maybe
we do 3 bits at a time.
So we go off to c to the 7th.
So here you would
grab the first 3 bits,
and that's what you would
compute here: c to the 1
0 1 to the 8th power.
And then, the rest is c
to the 1 0 1 power here.
It's a little unfortunate
these are the same thing,
but really there's
more bits here.
But here, this is
the thing that you're
going to look up in the table.
This is c to the 5th in decimal.
And this says you're going to
keep doing the sliding window
to compute this value.
Make sense?
This just saves
on how many times
you have to multiply
by c by pre-multiplying
it a bunch of times.
[? And the cell guys ?]
at least 10 years ago
thought that going
up to 32 power
was the best plan in
terms of efficiency
because there's some
trade off here, right?
You spend time
preconfiguring this table,
but then if this
table is too giant,
you're not going to
use some entries,
because if you run
this table out to,
I don't know, c to the 128
but you're computing just
like 500 [? full bit ?]
exponents,
maybe you're not going
to use all these entries.
So it's gonna be
a waste of time.
Question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Is there a reason
not to compute the
table [INAUDIBLE]?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It ends
up being the case
that you don't want to-- well
there's two things going on.
One is that you'll have now code
to check whether the entry is
filled in or not, and that'll
probably reduce your branch
predictor accuracy
on the CPU So it
will run slower
in the common case
because if you [INAUDIBLE]
with the entries there.
Another slightly
annoying thing is
that it turns out
this entry leaks stuff
through a different
side-channel, namely
cache access patterns.
So if you have some other
process on the same CPU,
you can sort of see which
cache addresses are getting
evicted out of the cache or are
slower because someone accessed
this entry or this entry.
And the bigger this
table gets, the easier
it is to tell what the
exponent bits were.
In the limit, this table is
gigantic and just telling,
just being able to tell which
cache address on this CPU
had a [? miss ?] tells you that
the encryption process must
have accessed that
entry in the table.
And tells you that, oh that long
bit sequence appears somewhere
in your secret key exponent.
So I guess the answer
isn't mathematically
you could totally fill
this in on demand.
In practice, you probably
don't want it to be that giant.
And also, if you have
it's particularly giant,
you aren't going to be able to
use entries as efficiently as
well.
You can reuse these
entries as you're
computing. [INAUDIBLE]
It's not actually
that expensive because
you use c to the cubed
when you're computing c to the
7th and so on and so forth.
It's not that bad.
Make sense?
Other questions?
All right.
So this is the repeated
squaring and sliding
window optimization that
open [? a cell ?] implements
[INAUDIBLE] I don't actually
know whether they still
have the same size of the
sliding window or not.
But it does actually give
you a fair bit of speed up.
So before you had to square
for every bit in the exponent.
And then you'd have to have
a multiply for every 1 bit.
So if you have a 500
bit exponent then
you're going to do 500
squarings and, on average,
roughly 256
multiplications by c.
So with sliding
windows, you're going
to still do the 512
squarings because there's
no getting around that.
But instead of doing
256 multiplies by c,
you're going to
hopefully do way fewer,
maybe something on the
order of 32 [INAUDIBLE]
multiplies by some
entry in this table.
So that's the general plan.
[INAUDIBLE] Not as
dramatic as CRT, not 2x,
but it could save
you like almost 1.5x.
All depending on exactly
what [INAUDIBLE].
Make sense?
Another question about this?
All right.
So these are the [? roughly ?]
easier optimizations.
And then there's
two clever tricks
playing with numbers for how to
do just a multiplication more
efficiently.
So the first one of
these optimizations
that we're going to
look at-- I think
I'll raise this board--
is called this Montgomery
representation.
And we'll see in
a second why it's
particularly important for us.
So the problem that this
Montgomery representation
optimization is
trying to solve for us
is the fact that every
time we do a multiply,
we get a number
that keeps growing
and growing and growing.
In particular, both
in sliding windows
or in repeated
squaring, actually when
you square you multiply
2 numbers together,
when you multiply
by c to the y, you
multiply 2 numbers together.
And the problem is that if the
inputs to the multiplication
were, let's say, 512 bits each.
Then the result of
the multiplication
is going to be 1,000 bits.
And then you'd take
this 1,000 bit result
and you multiply it
again by something
like five [INAUDIBLE] bits.
And now it's 1,500 bits,
2,000 bits, 2,500 bits,
and it keeps
growing and growing.
And you really don't want
this because multiplications
[? quadratic ?] in the size of
the number we're multiplying.
So we have to keep
the size of our number
as small as possible,
which means basically 512
bits because all this
computation is mod p or mod q.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What do
you want [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That's right, yeah.
So the cool thing is that
we can keep this number down
because what we
do is, let's say,
we want to compute c to the
x just for this example.
Squared.
Squared again.
What you could do is
you compute c to the x
then you take mod
p, let's say, right.
Then you square it then
you do mod p again.
Then you square it again,
and then you do mod p again.
And so on.
So this is basically
what you're proposing.
So this is great.
In fact, this keeps
it size of our numbers
to basically five total
bits, which is about as
small as we can get.
This is good in
terms of keeping down
the size of these numbers
for multiplication.
But it's actually kind of
expensive to do this mod p
operation.
Because the way that you
do mod p something is
you basically have
to do division.
And division is way worse
than multiplication.
I'm not going to go through
the algorithms for division,
but it's really slow.
You usually want to avoid
division as much as possible.
Because it's not even just a
straightforward programming
thing, you have to do some
approximation algorithm,
some sort of Newton's
method of some sort
and just keep it [INAUDIBLE].
It's going to be slow.
And in the main
implementation, this actually
turns out to be the slowest
part of doing multiplication.
The multiplication is cheap.
But then doing mod p or mod q
to bring it back down in size
is going to be actually more
expensive than the multiplying.
So that's actually
kind of a bummer.
So the way that we're
going to get around this
is by doing this multiplication,
this clever other
representation, and also
I'll show you the trick here.
Let's see.
Bear with me for a
second, and then we'll
and then see why it's so fast
to use this Montgomery trick.
And the basic idea is
to represent numbers,
these are regular numbers
that you might actually
want to multiply.
And we're going to have a
different representation
for these numbers, called the
Montgomery representation.
And that representation
is actually very easy.
We just take the value
a and we multiply it
by some magic value R.
I'll tell you what
this R is in a second.
But let's first figure out if
you pick some arbitrary value
R, what's going to happen here?
So we take 2 numbers, a and b.
Their Montgomery representations
are sort of expectedly.
A is aR, b is bR.
And if you want to compute
the product of a times b,
well in Montgomery
space, you can also
multiply these guys out.
You can take aR
multiply it by bR.
And what you get here
is ab times R squared.
So there are two Rs now.
That's kind of annoying, but
you can divide that by R.
And we get ab times R. So this
is probably weird in a sense
that why would you
multiply this extra number.
But let's first figure out
whether this is correct.
And then we'll figure out why
this is going to be faster.
So it's correct in the
sense that it's very easy.
If you want to
multiply some numbers,
we just multiply by this R
value and get the Montgomery
representation.
Then we can do all
these multiplications
to these Montgomery forms.
And every time we
multiply 2 numbers,
we have to divide by R,
look at the Montgomery
form of the
multiplication result.
And then when we're
done doing all
of our squarings,
multiplication, all this stuff,
we're going to move back
to the normal, regular form
by just dividing
by R one last time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: We're
now going to pick R
to be a very nice number.
And in particular,
we're going to pick R
to be a very nice number to make
this division by R very fast.
And the cool thing is
that if this division by R
is going to be very
fast, then this
is going to be a small
number and we're not
going to have to do
this mod q very often.
In particular, aR,
let's say, is also
going to be roughly 500 bits
because it's all actually
mod p or mod q.
So aR is 500 bits.
BR is going to also be 500 bits.
So this product is
going to be 1,000 bits.
This R is going to be
this nice 500 roughly bit
number, same size as p.
And if we can make this
division to be fast,
then the result is going to be
a roughly 500 bit number here.
So we were able to do the
multiplying without having
to do an extra divide.
Dividing by R cheaply gives us
this small result, getting us
out of doing a mod p
for most situations.
OK, so what is this weird number
that I keep talking about?
Well R is just going
to be 2 to 512.
It's going to be 1
followed by a ton of zeros.
So multiplying by
this is easy, you just
append a bunch of
zeros to a number.
Dividing could be easy if
the low bits of the result
are all zeros.
So if you have a value
that's a bunch of bits
followed by 512 zeros, then
dividing by 2 to the 512
is cheap.
You just discard the zeros
on the right-hand side.
And that's actually
the correct division.
Does that make sense?
The slight problem
is that we actually
don't have zeros on
the right hand side
when you do this multiplication.
These are like real 512 bit
numbers with all the 512 bits
used.
So this will be a
1,000 bit number
[? or ?] with all this bits
also set to randomly 0 or 1,
depending on what's going on.
So we can't just
discard the low bits.
But the cleverness
comes from the fact
that the only
thing we care about
is the value of
this thing mod p.
So you can always add
multiples of p to this value
without changing it when
it's equivalent to mod p.
And as a result, we
can add multiples of p
to get the low bits
to all be zeros.
So let's look through
some simple examples.
I'm not going to write
out 512 bits on the board.
But suppose that--
here's a short example.
Suppose that we have
a situation where
our value R is 2 to the 4th.
So it's 1 followed
by four zeros.
So this is a much smaller
example than the real thing.
But let's see how this
Montgomery division
is going to work out.
So suppose we're going to try
to compute stuff mod q, where
q, let's say, is maybe 7.
So this is 1 1 1 in binary form.
And what we're
going to try to do
is maybe we did
some multiplication.
And this value aR
times bR is equal
to this binary
presentation 1 1 0 1 0.
So this is going to be
the value of aR times bR.
How do we divide it by R?
So clearly the low
four bits aren't all 0,
so we can't just divide it out.
But we can add multiples of q.
In particular, we
can add 2 times q.
So 2q is equal to 1 1 1 0.
And now what we get
is 0 0, carry a 1, 0,
carry a 1, 1, carry a 1, 0 1.
I hope I did that right.
So this is what we get.
So now we get aR
bR plus 2 cubed.
But we actually don't care
about the plus 2 cubed.
It's actually fine
because all we care about
is the value of mod q.
And now we're closer, we have
three 0 bits at the bottom.
Now we can add
another multiple of q.
This time it's going
to be probably 8q.
So we add 1 1 1 here 0 0.
And if we add it, we're
going to get, let's say,
0 0 0 then add these two guys
0, carry a 1, 0, carry a 1, 1 1.
I think that's right.
But now we have
our original aR bR
plus 2q plus 8q is
equal to this thing.
And finally, we can divide
this thing by R very cheaply.
Because we just discard
the low four zeros.
Make sense?
Question.
AUDIENCE: Is aR bR always
going to end in, I guess,
1,024 zeros?
PROFESSOR: No, and the
reason is that-- OK,
here is the thing
that's maybe confusing.
A was, let's say, 512 bits.
Then you multiply it by
R. So here, you're right.
This value is that 1,000 bit
number where the high bit is
a, the high 512 bits are a.
And the low bits are all zeros.
But then, you're going
[? to do it with ?] mod
q to bring it down
to make it smaller.
And in general, this is
going to be the case.
Because [? it only ?] has
these low zeros the first time
you convert it.
But after you do a
couple multiplications,
they're going to
be arbitrary bits.
So these guys are--
so I really should
have written mod q here--
and to compute this mod q
as soon as you do the conversion
to keep the whole value small.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so the
initial conversion is expensive
or at least it's as expensive
as doing a regular modulus
during the multiplication.
The cool thing is
that you pay this cost
just once when you do the
conversion into Montgomery
form.
And then, instead of converting
it back at every step,
you just keep it
in Montgomery form.
But remember that in order
to do an exponentiation
to an exponent
which has 512 bits,
you're saying
you're going to have
to do over 500 multiplications
because we have to do at least
500 squarings plus then some.
So you do these mod
q twice and then
you get a lot of cheap divisions
if you stay in this form.
And then you do a division by R
to get back to this form again.
So instead of doing 500 mod qs
for every multiplication step,
you do it twice mod q.
And then you keep
doing these divisions
by R cheaply using this trick.
Question.
AUDIENCE: So when you're
adding the multiples of q
and then dividing
by R, [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Because it's
actually mod q means
the remainder when
you divide by q.
So x plus y times
q, mod q is just x.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So in this case,
dividing by-- so another sort
of nice property is
that because it's
all modulus at prime
number-- it's also true
that if you have x
plus yq divided by R,
mod q is actually the same
as x divided by R mod q.
The way to think of it is
that there's no real division
in modular arithmetic.
It's just an inverse.
So what this really
says is this is actually
x plus yq times some
number called R inverse.
And then you compute
this whole thing mod q.
And then you could think of
this as x times R inverse
mod q plus y [? u ?]
R inverse mod q.
And this thing cancels out
because it's something times q.
And there's some closed
form for this thing.
So here I did it by bit by
bit, 2q then 8q, et cetera.
It's actually a
nice closed formula
you can compute-- it's
in the lecture notes,
but it's probably not worth
spending time on the board
here-- for how do you figure
out what multiple of q
should you add to get all
the low bits to turn to 0.
So then it turns out that in
order to do this division by R,
you just need to compute this
magic multiple of q, add it.
And then discard the
low bits and that
brings your number back to 512
bits, or whatever the size is.
OK.
And here's the subtlety.
The only reason we're
talking about this
is that there's something
funny going on here
that is going to allow us
to learn timing information.
And in particular, even
though we divided by R,
we know the result is
going to be 512 bits.
But it still might
be greater than q
because q isn't exactly
[? up to 512 ?],
it's not a 512 bit number.
So it might be a
little bit less than R.
So it might be that after we
do this cheap division by R,
[? the way ?] we
subtract out q one more
time because we get something
that's small but not
quite small enough.
So there's a chance that
after doing this division,
we maybe have to also
subtract q again.
And this subtraction is
going to be part of what
this attack is all about.
It turns out that
subtracting this q adds time.
And someone figured
out-- not these guys
but some previous
work-- that you
show that this probability
of doing this thing, this
is called an
extractor reduction.
This probability sort of
depends on the particular value
that you're exponentiating.
So if you're computing
x to the d mod q,
the probability of
an extra reduction,
at some point while
computing x to the d mod q,
is going to be equal to
x mod q divided by 2R.
So if we're going to be
computing x to the mod q,
then depending on what
the value of x mod q
is, whether it's
big or small, you're
going to have even more or
less of these extra reductions.
And just to show you where
this is going to fit in,
this is actually going to
happen in the decrypt step,
because during the decrypt
step, the server is going
to be computing c to the d.
And this says the
extractor reductions
are going to be proportional to
how close x, or c in this case,
is to the value q.
So this is going to
be worrisome, right,
because the attacker gets
to choose the input c.
And the number of
extractor reductions
is going to be proportional
to how close the c is
to one of the factors, the q.
And this is how you're going
to tell I'm getting close
to the q, or I've overshot q.
And all of a sudden, there's
no extractor reductions,
it's probably because x mod
q is very small the x is
q plus little epsilon.
And it's very small.
So that's one part
of the timing attack
we're going to be
looking at in a second.
I don't have any proof that
this actually true [INAUDIBLE]
these extractor
reductions work like this.
Yea, question.
AUDIENCE: What happens if you
don't do this extra reduction?
PROFESSOR: Oh, what happens
if you don't do this extractor
reduction?
You can avoid this
extra reduction.
And then you just have
to do some extra probably
modular reductions later.
I think the math just
works out nicely this way
for the Montgomery form.
I think for many of these
things it's actually
once you look at them as a
timing channel [INAUDIBLE]
[? think ?] don't
do this at all,
or maybe you should
do some other plan.
So you're right,
I think you could probably
avoid this extra reduction
and probably just do the
mod q, perhaps at the end.
I haven't actually
tried implementing this.
But it seems like it could work.
It might be that you just
have to do mod q once
[? there ?], which you'll
probably have to do anyway.
So it's not super clear.
Maybe it's [INAUDIBLE]
probably not q.
So in light of the
fact that [INAUDIBLE].
Actually, I shouldn't speak
authoritatively to this.
I haven't tired
implementing this.
So maybe there's some deep
reason why this extractor
reduction has to happen.
I couldn't think of one.
All right, questions?
So here's the last piece of
the puzzle for how OpenSSL,
this library that this
paper attacks implements
multiplication.
So this Montgomery trick is
great for avoiding the mod q
part during modular
multiplication.
But then there's a question
of how do you actually
multiply two numbers together.
So we're doing lower
and lower level.
So suppose you have
[? the raw ?] multiplication.
So this is not even
modular multiplication.
You have two numbers, a and b.
And both these guys
are 512 bit numbers.
How do you multiply
them together
when your machine is
only a 32 bit machine,
like the guys in the paper, or
a 64 bit, but still, same thing?
How would you implement
multiplication of these guys?
Any suggestions?
Well I guess it was a
straightforward question,
you just represent a and
b as a sequence of machine
[? words. ?] And then you
just do this quadratic product
of these two guys.
[INAUDIBLE] see a simple
example, instead of thinking
of a 512 bit number, let's think
of these guys as 64 bit numbers
and we're on a 32 bit machine.
Right.
So we're going to have values.
The value of a is going
to be represented by two
[? very ?] different things.
It's going to be, let's
call it, a1 and a0.
So a0 is the low bit,
a1 is the high bit.
And similarly, we're
going to represent
b as two things, b1 b0.
So then a naive way
to represent a b
is going to be to multiply
all these guys out.
So it's going to be
a three cell number.
The high bit is
going to be a1 b1.
The low bit is
going to be a0 b0.
And the middle word is going
to be a1 b0 plus a0 b1.
So this is how you do the
multiplication, right.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So I was
going to say are
you using [INAUDIBLE] method?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so this
is like a clever method
alternative for doing
multiplication, which
doesn't involve four steps.
Here, you have to do
four multiplications.
There's this clever
other method, Karatsuba.
Do they teach this in 601
or something these days?
AUDIENCE: 042.
PROFESSOR: 042, excellent.
Yeah, that's a very nice method.
Almost every cryptographic
library implements this.
And for those of
you that, I guess,
weren't undergrads here, since
we have grad students maybe
they haven't seen Karatsuba.
I'll just write it
out on the board.
It's a clever thing the
first time you see it.
And what you can do is basically
compute out three values.
You're going to
compute out a1 b1.
You're going to also
compute a1 minus b0 times b1
minus-- sorry-- a1
minus a0, b1 minus b0.
And a0 b0.
And this does three
multiplications
instead of four.
And it turns out
you can actually
reconstruct this value from
these three multiplication
results.
And the particular
way to do it is this
is going to be the--
let me write it out
in a different form.
So we're going to have 2 to the
64 times-- sorry-- 2 to the 64
plus 2 to the 32
times a1 b1 plus 2
to the 32 times minus that
little guy in the middle a1
minus a0 b1 minus b0.
And finally, we're going to do
2 to the 32 plus 1 times a0 b0.
And it's a little
messy, but actually
if you work through
the details, you'll
end up convincing
yourself hopefully
that this value is exactly
the same as this value.
So it's a clever.
But nonetheless, it saves
you one multiplication.
And the way we
apply this to doing
much larger multiplications
is that you recursively
keep going down.
So if you have 512
bit values, you
could break it down to
256 bit multiplication.
You do three 256
bit multiplications.
And then each of
those you're going
to do using the same
Karatsuba trick recursively.
And eventually you'll get
down to machine size, which
you can just do with
a single machine
instruction. [INAUDIBLE]
This make sense?
So what's the
timing attack here?
How do these guys exploit
this Karatsuba multiplication?
Well, it turns out
that OpenSSL worries
about basically two
kinds of multiplications
that you might need to do.
One is a multiplication
between two large numbers
that are about the same size.
So this happens a
lot when we're doing
this modular exponentiation
because all the values we're
going to be multiplying
are all going
to be roughly 512 bits in size.
So when we're multiplying by c
to the y or doing a squaring,
we're multiplying two things
that are about the same size.
And then this Karatsuba
trick makes a lot of sense
because, instead
of computing stuff
in times squared
of the input size,
Karatsuba is roughly n to the
1.58, something like that.
So it's much faster.
But then there's
this other situation
where OpenSSL might be
multiplying two numbers that
are very different in
size: one that's very big,
and one that's very small.
And in that case you
could use Karatsuba,
but then it's going
to get you slower
than doing the naive thing.
Suppose you're trying
to multiply a 512 bit
number by a 64 bit
number, you'd rather just
do the straightforward
thing, where you just
multiply by each of the
things in the 64 bit
number plus 2n instead of
n to the 1.58 something.
So as a result, the OpenSSL
guys tried to be clever,
and that's where
often problems start.
They decided that
they'll actually
switch dynamically between
this Karatsuba efficient thing
and this sort of grade school
method of multiplication here.
And their heuristic
was basically
if the two things
you're multiplying
are exactly the same
number of machine words,
so they at least
have the same number
of bits up to 32-bit units,
then they'll go to Karatsuba.
And if the two things
they're multiplying
have a different
number or 32 bit units,
then they'll do the quadratic
or straightforward or regular,
normal multiplication.
And there you can see if
your number all of a sudden
switches to be a
little bit smaller,
then you're going to switch
from the sufficient thing
to this other
multiplication method.
And presumably, the
cutoff point isn't
going to be exactly
smooth so you'll
be able to tell all
of a sudden, it's
now taking a lot
longer to multiply
or a lot shorter to
multiply than before.
And that's what these guys
exploit in their timing attack
again.
Does that make sense?
What's going on with the
[INAUDIBLE] All right.
So I think I'm now
done with telling you
about all the weird
implementation
tricks that people play when
implementing RSA in practice.
So now let's try to
put them back together
into an entire web
server and figure out
how do you [? tickle ?]
all these interesting bits
of the implementation from
the input network packet.
So what happens
in a web server is
that the web server, if
you remember from the HTTPS
lecture, has a secret key.
And it uses the
secret key to prove
that it's the
correct owner of all
that certificate in the
HTTPS protocol or in TLS.
And they way this works is that
the clients send some randomly
chosen bits, and the
bits are encrypted
using the server's public key.
And the server in this TLS
protocol decrypts this message.
And if the message
checks out, it
uses those random bits to
establish a [? session ?].
But in this case, the message
isn't going to check out.
The message is going
to be carefully chosen,
the padding bits
aren't going to match,
and the server is
going to return error
as soon as it finishes
encrypting our message.
And that's what we're
going to time here.
So the server-- you can think of
this is Apache with open SSL--
you're going to get a
message from the client,
and you can think of
this as a ciphertext
c, or a hypothetical
ciphertext, that the client
might have produced.
And the first thing we're going
to do with a ciphertext c,
we want to decrypt it
using roughly this formula.
And if you remember
the first optimization
we're going to apply is the
Chinese Remainder Theorem.
So the first thing
we're going to do
is basically split our
pipeline in two parts.
We're going to do one thing
mod p another thing mod q
and then recombine the
results at the end of the day.
So the first thing
we're going to do
is, we're actually
going to take c
and we're going
to compute, let's
call this c0, which is going
to be equal to c mod q.
And we're also going to have
a different value, let's
call it c1, which is
going to be c mod p.
And then we're going to
do the same thing to each
of these values to basically
compute c to the d mod p
and c to the d mod q.
And here we're going to
basically initially we're
going to [? starch. ?]
After CRT, we're
going to switch into
Montgomery representation
because that's going to make
our multiplies very fast.
So the next thing
SSL is going to do
to your number,
it's actually going
to compute all the
[INAUDIBLE] at c0 prime,
which is going to
be c0 times R mod q.
And the same thing
down here, I'm
not going to write
out the pipeline
because that'll look the same.
And then, now that we've
switched into Montgomery form,
we can finally do
our multiplications.
And here's where we're going
to use the sliding window
technique.
So once we have c
prime, we can actually
try to compute this prime
exponentiate it to 2d mod q.
And here, as we're computing
this value to the d,
we're going to be
using sliding windows.
So here, we're going
to do sliding windows
for the bits in this d exponent.
And also we're going
to do Karatsuba
or regular multiplication
depending on exactly what
the size of our operands are.
So if it turns out that the
thing we're multiplying,
c0 prime and maybe that
previously squared result,
are the same size, we're
going to do Karatsuba.
If c0 prime is tiny
but some previous thing
we're multiplying it to is
big , then we're going to do
quadratic multiplication,
normal multiplication.
There's sliding
windows coming in here,
here we also have this Karatsuba
versus normal multiplying.
And also in this step, the
extra reductions come in.
Because at every multiply,
the extra reductions
are going to be proportional
to the thing we're
exponentiating mod q.
[INAUDIBLE] just plug in
the formula over here,
the probability
extra reductions is
going to be proportional to
this value of c0 prime mod
q divided by 2R.
So this is where the
really timing sensitive bit
is going to come in.
And there are actually
two effects here.
There's this Karatsuba
versus normal choice.
And then there's the
number of extra reductions
you're going to be making.
So we'll see how we
exploit this in a second,
but now that you get
this result for mod q,
you're going to get a
similar result mod p,
you can finally recombine
these guys from the top
and the bottom and use CRT.
And what you get out
from CRT is actually--
sorry I guess we need a first
convert it back down into non
Montgomery form.
So we're going to
get first, we're
going to get c0 prime to
the d divided by R mod q.
And this thing, because c0
prime was c0 times R mod q,
if we do this then we're going
to get back out our value of c
to the d mod q.
And we get c to
the d here, we're
going to get to c to the d
mod p on the bottom version
of this pipeline.
And we can use CRT to get the
value of c to the d mod m.
Sorry for the small
type here, or font size.
But roughly it's the same
thing we're expecting here.
We can finally get our result.
And we get our message, m.
So the server takes
an incoming packet
that it gets, runs it
through this whole pipeline,
does two parts of
this pipeline, ends up
with a decrypted message m
that's equal c to the d mod m.
And then it's going to check
the padding of this message.
And in this particular
attack, because we're
going to carefully
construct this value c,
the padding is going to
actually not match up.
We're going to choose
the value c according
to some other
heuristics that aren't
encrypting a real message
with the correct padding.
So the padding is going to be
a mismatch, and the server's
going to need it to record
an error back to the client.
[? And it pulls ?]
the connection.
And that's the time
that we're going
to measure to figure out how
long this whole pipeline took.
Makes sense?
Questions about this
pipeline and putting
all the optimizations together?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
you're probably right.
Yes, c1 to the d, c0 to the d.
Yeah, this is c0.
Yeah, correct.
AUDIENCE: When you
divide by r [INAUDIBLE],
isn't there a
[INAUDIBLE] on how many
q's you have to have to get
the [? little bit ?] to be
0? [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so there
might be extra reductions
in this final phase as well.
You're right.
So potentially, we have do
this divide by R correctly.
So we probably have to
do exactly the same thing
as we saw for the
Montgomery reductions here.
When we do this divide
by R to convert it back.
So it's not clear exactly
how many qs we should add.
We should figure out how many
qs to add, add that many,
kill the low zeros, and
then do mod q again,
maybe an extra reduction.
You're absolutely
right, this is exactly
the same kind of
divide by R mod q
as we do for every Montgomery
multiplication step.
Make sense?
Any other questions?
All right.
So how do you exploit this?
How does an attacker
actually figure out
what the secret
key of the server
is by measuring the time
of this entire pipeline?
So these guys have a
plan that basically
involves guessing one bit of
the private key at a time.
And what they mean actually
by guessing the private key is
that you might think the private
key is this encryption exponent
d, because actually
you know e, you
know n, that's the public key.
The only think you
don't know is d.
But in fact, in this attack
they don't go for the exponent d
directly, that's a little
bit harder to guess.
Instead, what
they're going to go
for is the value
q or the value p,
doesn't really matter which one.
Once you guess what the
value p or q is, then
you can give an n, you can
factor in the p times q.
Then if you know p times
q, you can actually--
sorry-- if you know
the values of p and q,
you can compute that phi
function we saw before.
That's going to allow you to get
the value d from the value e.
So this factorization of the
value m is hugely important,
it should be secret for
RSA to remain secure.
So these guys are
actually going to go
and try to guess
what the value of q
is by timing this pipeline.
All right.
So how do these
guys actually do it?
Well, they construct
carefully chosen inputs, c,
into this pipeline
and-- I guess I
keep saying they keep measuring
the time for this guy.
But the particular,
well, there's
two parts of the
attack, you have
to bootstrap it a little bit to
guess the first couple of bits.
And then once you have
the first couple of bits,
you can I guess the next bit.
So let me not say
exactly how they
guess the first couple of bits
because it's actually much more
interesting to see how
they guess the next bit.
And then we'll come
back if we have
time to look at how they
guess the first couple of bits
[? at this ?] in the paper.
But basically, suppose you
have a guess g about what
the bits are of this value q.
So you know that q has some
bits, g0, g1, g2, et cetera.
And actually, I guess
these are not even gs,
these are real q bits, so
let me write it as that.
So you know tat q bit
0 q bit 1, q bit 2,
these are the highest bits of q.
And then you're trying to
guess lower and lower bits.
So suppose you know the
value of q up to bit j.
And from that point on, your
guess is actually all 0.
You have no idea what
the other bits are.
So these guys are going
to try to get this guess
g into this place
in the pipeline.
Because this is where
there are two tiny effects:
this choice of Karatsuba
versus normal multiplication.
And this choice of, or
this a different number
of extra reductions depending
on the value c0 prime.
Sp they're going to actually
try to get two different guess
values into that
place in the pipeline.
One that looks like this,
and one that they call
g high, which is all the
same high bits, q2 qj.
And for the next bit,
which they don't know,
[? you ?] guess g
is going to have 0,
g high is going to have a bit
1 here and all zeros later on.
So how does it help these guys
figure out what's going on?
So there are really two
ways you can think of it.
Suppose that we get this guess
g to be the value of c0 prime.
We can think of g and g high
being the c0 prime value
on that left board over there.
It's actually fairly
straightforward
to do this because c0 prime
is pretty deterministically
computed from the
input ciphertext c0.
You just multiply it
by R. So, in order
for them to get
some value to here,
as a guess, they just
need to take their guess
and first divide it by R, so
divide it by 2 to the 512 mod
something.
And then, they're going
to inject it back.
And the server's going
to multiply it by R,
and then off you go.
Make sense?
All right.
So suppose that we manage to get
our particular chosen integer
value into that c0
you're prime spot.
So what's going to be
the time to compute
c0 prime to the d mod q?
So there are two possible
options here where
q falls in this picture.
So it might be that q is
between these two values.
Because the next bit of q is 0.
So this value is going
to be less than q,
but this guy's going
to be greater than q.
So this happens if the
next bit of q0 or it
might be that q lies
above both of these values
if the next bit of q is 1.
So now we can tell,
OK, what's going
to be the timing of
decrypting these two values,
if q lies in between them, or
if q lies above both of them.
Let's look at the
situation where
q lies above both of them.
Well in that case,
actually everything
is pretty much the same.
Right?
Because both of these
values are smaller than q,
then the value of
these things mod q
is going to be roughly the same.
They're going to be a
little bit different
because this extra bit,
but more or less they're
the same magnitude.
And the number of
extractor reductions
is also probably not going to
be hugely different because it's
proportional to the
value of this guy mod q.
And for both these guys, they're
both a little bit smaller
than q, so they're
all about the same.
Neither of them is going to
exceed q and all of a sudden
have [? many or fewer ?]
extra reductions.
So if q is greater than
both of these guesses
then Karatsuba versus normal
is going to stay the same.
The server is going to do
the same thing basically
for both g and g high in terms
of Karatsuba versus normal.
And the server's going to
do about the same number
of extra reductions for
both these guys as well.
So If you see that the server's
taking the same amount of time
to respond to these
guesses, then you
should probably guess that, oh,
q probably has the bit 1 here.
On the other hand, if
q lies in the middle,
then there are two
possible things
that could trigger a
change in the timing.
One possibility is
that because g high
is just a little
bit larger than q,
then the number of
extra reductions
is going to be proportional
to this guy mod q, which
is very small because
c0 prime is q plus just
a little bit in
these extra bits.
So the number of
extra reductions
is going to [? flaunt it ?].
And all of a sudden,
it will be faster.
Another possible
thing that can happen
is that maybe the
server will decide, oh,
now it's time to do normal
multiplication instead
of Karatsuba.
Maybe for this value,
all these, c to the 0
prime was the same
number of bits as q
if it turns out that
g high is above q,
then g high mod q is potentially
going to have fewer bits.
And if this crosses the
[INAUDIBLE] boundary,
then the server's going to
do normal multiplication
all of a sudden.
So that's going to be
in the other direction.
So if you cross over, then
normal multiplication kicks in,
and things get a lot slower
because normal multiplication
is quadratic instead of
nicer, faster Karatsuba.
Question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, because the
number of extra reductions
is proportional to from above
there to c0 prime mod q.
So if c0 prime, which is this
value, is just a little over q.
Then, this is tiny, as opposed
to this guy who's basically
the same as q, or all the
high bits are the same as q,
and then it's big.
So then it'll be the difference
that you can try to measure.
So this is one interesting
thing, actually
a couple interesting
things, these effects
actually work in different
directions, right.
So if you hit a 32 bit
boundary and Karatsuba
versus normal switches,
then all of a sudden
it takes much longer to
decrypt this message.
On the other hand, if it's
not a 32 bit boundary,
maybe this effect will
tell you what's going on.
So you actually have to
watch for different effects.
If you're not guessing a bit
that's a multiple of 32 bits,
then you should
probably expect the time
to drop because of
extra reductions.
On the other hand,
if you're trying
to guess a bit that's
a multiple of 32, then
maybe you should be expecting
for it to jump a lot
or maybe drop if it's
[INAUDIBLE] normal.
So I guess what these
guys look at in the paper,
this actually
doesn't really matter
whether there's a jump up
or a jump down in time.
You should just expect if q
is, if the next bit of q is 1,
you should expect
these things to take
almost the same amount of time.
And if the next bit
of q is 0, then you
should expect these guys to
have a noticeable difference
even if it's big or small, even
if it's positive or negative.
So actually, they measure this.
And it turns out to
actually work pretty well.
They have to do actually
two interesting tricks
to make this work out.
If you remember the timing
difference was tiny,
it's an order of 1
to 2 microseconds.
So it's going to be hard to
measure this over a network,
over an ethernet
switch for example.
What they do is they actually
do two kinds of measurements,
two kinds of averaging.
So for each guess
that they send,
they actually send
it several times.
In the paper, they
said they send it
like 7 times or something.
So what kind of
noise do you think
this helps them with
[? if they ?] just resend
the same guess over and over?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What's up
with the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
if the network keeps
adding different
things, you just
try the same thing many times.
The thing in the
server should be
taking exactly the same
amount of time every time
and just average out
the network noise.
In the paper, they say they take
the median value-- I actually
don't understand why
they take the median,
I think they should be taking
the min of the real thing
that's going on--
but anyway, this
was the average of the network.
But then they do this
other weird thing,
which is that when
they're sending a guess,
they don't just send
the same guess 7 times,
they actually send a
neighborhood of guesses.
And each value in
the neighborhood
gets sent 7 times itself.
So they actually send g 7 times.
Then they send g
plus 1 also 7 times.
Then they send g plus 2 also
7 times, et cetera, up to g
plus 400 in the paper.
Why do they do this
kind of averaging
as well over different g value
instead of just sending g
7 times 400 times.
Because it seems
more straightforward.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's
actually what's going on.
We're actually trying to measure
exactly how long this piece
of computation will take.
But then there's
lots of other stuff.
For example, this other
pipeline that's at the bottom
is doing all the stuff mod p.
I mean it's also going to
take different amount of time
depending on what
exactly the input is.
So the cool thing is
that if you perturb
the value of all your
guess g by adding 1, 2, 3,
whatever, it's just
[INAUDIBLE] the little bits.
So the timing attack we
just looked at just now,
isn't going to change
because that depended
on this middle bit flipping.
But everything that's
happening on the bottom side
of the pipeline mod p
is going to be totally
randomized by this
because when they
do it mod p then
adding an extra bit
could shift things
around quite a bit mod p.
Then you're going to,
it will average out
other kinds of
computational noise
that's deterministic
for a particular value
but it's not related to this
part of the computation we're
trying to go after.
Make sense?
AUDIENCE: How do they
do that when they
try to guess the lower bits?
PROFESSOR: So actually they use
some other mathematical trick
to only actually bother guessing
the top half of the bits of q.
It turns out if you know the
top half of the bits of q
there's some math you can
rely on to factor the numbers,
and then you're in good shape.
So you can always
[INAUDIBLE] little bit.
Basically not worry about it.
Make sense?
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, you're going to
construct this value c0-- well
you want the c0 prime-- you're
going to construct a value
c by basically taking your c0
prime and multiplying it times
R inverse mod n.
And then when the
server takes this value,
it's going to push
it through here.
So it's going to compute c0.
It's going to be c mod
q, so that value is going
to be c0 prime R inverse mod q.
Then you multiply it by R, so
you get rid of the R inverse.
And then you end up with a
guess exactly in this position.
So the cool thing is
basically all manipulations
leading up to here are
just multiplying by this R.
And you know what R is going be,
it's going to be 2 to the 512.
I'm going to be really
straightforward.
Make sense?
Another question?
AUDIENCE: Could we just
cancel out timing [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, if you do
p, you'd be in business.
Yeah, so that's the thing.
Yeah, you don't know
what p is, but you just
want to randomize it out.
Any questions?
All right. [INAUDIBLE] but
thanks for sticking around.
So we'll start talking about
other kinds of problems
next week.